what I want to bring you back to is this
question which was our number four in
our view questions okay now you've had a
bit of a go at actually getting yourself
more comfortable with a reverse chain
rule now which explains the way that so
if he actually came up with this answer
she used the reverse chain rule let's
just quickly check and see how it worked
okay
we've actually got this index here right
and it increases by one so I've got X
plus three it increases up to three and
then what has she done with that new
index
she's divided by that right I mean I'm
just gonna write it like so she's
divided by that okay now at this point
she writes her concert in integration
but there is actually sneakily hiding an
extra thing which reverse chain rule
requires us to do it just happens to
have no impact on this can anyone tell
me what's the missing thing that hasn't
been written straighten go ahead you
were so close into the second last word
we have we need to do the outside the
inside in the outside as string says the
part that we had done is the actual
outside it's a sting to the power of two
so it's it's gone up to three and divide
it well what we haven't done is the
inside right which is x plus so you said
I think you meant the right thing it
just came out right which I do all the
time okay so it's the inside we haven't
dealt with right what is the derivative
or I should say what is the inside
function its X plus three so therefore
the derivative the inside function is
its one what do I do that one by where
does it actually go it's it's down here
in the denominator but of course it
makes the impact so you like find this
answer is correct there's the there's
the a from the inside there
all right now this is the important part
because it actually raises some
questions for what integration means and
the results we get from it I said that
this is not the only way to do it
because most of you actually didn't know
how to do this at the beginning of a
lesson you've looked at your what where
do I go with this okay now I gave you a
suggestion who rubbed it off because I
wanted to do it here again and I'd love
you if you didn't do this to follow with
me right even if you don't know the
reverse chain rule you can deal with
this int and put it into a form that
doesn't require the reverse chain I'll
show you I'm gonna write the integration
sign because the next thing I'm about to
do is not integration it's just
rearranging the integrand so it's a
little easier or tidier to work with
okay I'm gonna take this X plus 3l
squared and I'm gonna expand it okay now
we usually dislike expansion because
well there's it's longer and there's
more stuff to right usually we don't
like that however in the case of
differentiation integration I kind of
feel like oh it's nice I can just go one
term at a time I don't need to keep
inside and outside in my head I can just
go through it in a fairly methodical way
so I'm just going to have a go at doing
this the x squared term
now I'm gonna integrate it it becomes X
cubed on three good done what is this do
I become 6x squared on - and I'm gonna
encourage you by the way particularly
these early stages even if you feel like
you can resist simplifying this on the
first line to 3x squared even though it
clearly is because for you I want your
brain to get in the habit of doing this
you're so good at doing it in the
opposite direction if you go straight to
3x squared like 75% of the time you'll
get it right and 25% of time you'll get
it wrong and you won't know why because
your brain is canceled something it
wasn't supposed to cancel and you won't
have any working that helps you see what
went wrong okay that's done
the nine becomes and then lastly okay
fantastic
now this is the result now we were
having a look at this to remember this
and we're like wow all these different
ways of writing our indefinite integral
and I said to you are these all the same
now I really want you to help me out
here and see if you can help me
determine are these actually the same
because something
we and sort of emerges when you do this
X plus three all cued it's gonna take us
second four I'd like us to actually put
the effort in and expand it
you're never gonna say oh I wish I had
spent less time actually getting good at
my algebra here so let's practice these
skills X was 3 cubed is X plus 3 times X
plus 3 times X plus 3 now thankfully
we've already expanded one of those this
is X plus 3 or squared we just did that
over here right so there's X plus 3 and
there's X plus 3 times X plus 3 game ok
that's all divided by 3 and then my
constant so these are two lines of
working my constants hanging around the
end ok help me out here to expand this
what do I have to do x times all that
stuff and then three times all that
stuff can I give you 20 seconds to go
and do that now please go ahead I'll
give you a head start and then I'll show
you what I come up with
I hope you've arrived I've got this
result here I've down the bottom you
you're welcome to check it across what
you've got um you'll notice just before
we discuss that answer my previous line
I've written in a slightly unusual way
that I would wager very few people in
the room have probably written but I'm
gonna encourage you if you ever have to
do so like this and sometimes you do
it's not a bad way to do it I've
arranged my second last line in
particular way anyone tell me how I did
it I lined them up I've got X cubes and
then I've got X Squared's and then I've
got X's and then I've got this constant
hang around the end now you of course
don't need to write it like this to do
the addition correctly but it just kind
of makes it easier from a brain in fact
you might even some of you who were
clever and we're paying attention might
have noticed I actually wrote it wrong
the first time because my brain was on
autopilot
I wrote this is a 9x squared instead of
9x but then when I looked at I was like
where's not that's wrong but my my X's
didn't line up so I knew it was kind of
like a self checking algorithm this is
my answer that I've ended up with okay
now I hope when you've gotten to this
point you've noticed something weird
let's just check this against what we
thought we should have gotten first term
it's X cubed on three right so there's
my X cubed on three and that checks out
ya next time ever 9x squared on three
what's that that's 3x squared
this guy here which again that checks
out right then you come over to 27 X
divided by 3 which is 9 X that also
checks out and then you're like wait a
second
well what's going on right now now hold
on hold on hold on
my answer is no longer seemed to agree
with each other right except that they
do
tell me again what plus C is it's the
constant of integration but what it
stands for it's a bit sneaky right
usually usually a plus C stands for a
premium right usually it stands for a
single number but any indefinite
integrals like this they kind of stand
for every number plus two plus five
minus a thousand they could be anything
so in fact plus C and 27 plus C they're
just different numbers that stand for
well I can move this function up and
down wherever I like so actually we do
end up with the same result whether we
got it from reverse chain rule or from
expanding this or could working here the
one that well didn't want to do right
was it necessary was it necessary it
wasn't it was just to confirm that we
got the right answer using reverse chain
rule and just arrived at this answer
immediately is faster it's less
error-prone it's the way to go now that
you know how to do it but I just want to
show you why sometimes you'll get
discrepancies you'll look at your answer
in the person next to you or your answer
and the textbook you're like why are
they different sometimes they aren't
actually different at all no well this
27 is not completely useless but it's
sort of it sort of absorbs into that
plus C it's just like well there's some
constant over here okay and the C here
could be 10 and this C could be 37
well no because these two seas here may
actually be different numbers yeah so we
will get later on to working out what C
is right we actually can in certain
circumstances if you've got more
information you can work out what C is
if this C is 4 then that C is going to
be negative 23 to make up for